hey annie i heard that you're a stand-up
comedian is that true yes it is and i
heard you dabble too in the art i do and
we're going places um where are we going
so next week i'll be at the helium
comedy club in indianapolis and i'm very
excited friday saturday and then i'm
going to philly san diego austin
brooklyn washington dc and chicago and
you can get tickets at esther on ice.com
and annie what's your deal i am going to
be in richmond virginia this weekend at
the sandman comedy club i know i'm going
back i'm going back east baby las vegas
nevada
i'm going to be in san francisco i'm
going to be in new york i'm going to be
in florida again burbank california
austin texas i'm going to be in arizona
i have so many dates michigan there's a
million please go to my website
andyletterman.com shows
and i do want to say
my
boyfriend my dear todd's show that he
worked on on netflix is out right now
it's called making fun
it's probably already on the top but
let's make it happen it's really cool
making fun on netflix i can't wait to
watch you guys we have a live stream
show it's going to be
so
messed up
and unedited what you don't realize is
the things that you don't see on this
show you're going to see them on
wednesday march 30th at 6 00 p.m pacific
time and let's get cancelled
baby you can get tickets at
momenthouse.com
trash tuesday and we have an early bird
special for only the first 24 hours of
this coming out today on march 8th you
can get an early bird price if you think
we're an edgy show now
just you wait you have not seen anything
yet
dude all parents are my can you block my
parents ip address because i don't i am
going to oh you know what they'll never
pay you should block dave too i'm going
to ruin your life esther's going down
you guys we're ruining all of our lives
this is a one-time deal you want to go
to momenthouse.com
trash tuesday and sign up right now
esther i've had time to mull it over i
know
what
here's what i've had time to mull over
and i unlike andrew schultz my
he doesn't his mouth doesn't have to
check in with his brain no like it just
operates at such high speeds that when
he says something i don't have like a
comeback or like i know i don't know if
he means what he said i don't know if
it's a joke i don't know if it's both a
joke and true he's a genius
oh absolutely like him fully announcing
that he doesn't eat [ __ ] like proudly
is absolutely iconic
like at first i'm like [ __ ] you but then
i'm like no he took a strong stance and
then we all have to like fight it out
and like tell him why he's wrong and it
was like an open fun discussion but also
that is a preference in the same way
that i know girls who don't like to blow
dudes
and they stand firmly about that and
you know um here's what they will
happily ride andrew schultz's dick they
just don't want correct blow it right
and that also we should be okay with
those preferences yeah yeah no well
i
we just won't date a guy like that
you're free to not go down on women as
much as you want to not do that that's
fine but delete my number
imagine there are probably women who
don't like being gone down on yeah that
has to exist as well right right
um but here's what i've had the chance
to mull over he was talking about the
volume of a [ __ ] and how the bigger the
girl the bigger the volume and that
couldn't be more wrong the tiniest
friend i have and this isn't you
the the skin i swear to god she weighs
about 95 pounds
she tells me every day she's like kala i
need massive [ __ ] my vagina goes up to
here like i need
the biggest dick in the world like she's
a size queen and she's tiny oh my god i
love this and i know a bigger girl who
can barely get
like those little vibrators in there or
the little um dildos in there
so it the volume of the [ __ ] has no
correlation with the size of the woman
that makes so much more that's what i
always thought but then he was like
throwing this game at us and i like i
was like okay i guess i can just be a
pick me girl and like agree with him
that yes because i'm small my [ __ ] is
small but ultimately like that's [ __ ]
not true and i'm so sick of guys telling
me that i don't know what a big dick is
you have no idea
how many times in my life men are like
you don't really know what a big dick is
and i didn't stand up for myself and i
wish i would have but i do think that i
know what a big dick is when i see it
okay i think we need a redo whenever
chance when the next chance we get to do
flagrant two again we have to address
these things we have to go in there and
just i'm so ready to go back he andrew
[ __ ] call us call us back
have us back there was also
i don't want to get too aggressive
towards andrew but i do have a theory
since re-watching our episode
because you notice how he was very quick
to tell me that he doesn't think i'm i
could be bi that he thinks i just like
i just like you as a friend which i do
but like
but i have a theory
i'm like oh is he projecting on to me
that he wants to [ __ ] me because he
wishes that i was fully straight because
i've only ever gotten that pushback from
straight men i feel like they they meet
me and they assume that i'm this like
little straight baby and they want to
[ __ ] me and like if i how dare i like i
couldn't possibly like women i just need
their dick
what thoughts interesting i
we'd have to you know it has to come
from the horse's mouth i think if he
wants to [ __ ] you or not fair but
i will say that that is strategy
it i think that men do employ that
strategy i'm like no you they almost
like invalidate
your sexuality because
they don't you are on their [ __ ] list
yes yes
and andrew like
whatever it is let me know let's talk it
out like much love
there's nothing wrong with wanting to
[ __ ] me secretly
nothing wrong with it
[ __ ]
ani's here yes
there's nothing wrong with wanting to
[ __ ] you
guess there is you're all on the list
everyone that's ever commented that they
want to bang esther is going to prison
um carlos do you want to hold my key
to my car oh oh my god
no way you got your chest today today no
way i can't believe you showed up
i know i almost left i almost went to
mexico but it doesn't have enough of a
charge i haven't figured out how to
charge it yet
wait this is major teles everywhere wow
you guys are earrings that this
beautiful woman in florida made for me
whose name i can't remember thank you so
much well at least thank you for
remembering my name
can we put the air up a little bit it's
is it really hot in here i i'm rude i
smell bad
no my arms look at me no that's fine
with me put that i haven't been sweating
a lot yeah it's very hot out today annie
here what's going on you got a [ __ ]
tesla i got a tesla
i have two you have teacher nails i have
two yeah it says write a book
oh my god
and i did start it manifesting yeah
that's so cute you should get a a tattoo
that says write a book do you know that
everyone is making me uh sign their arms
like the kalila tattoo that's brilliant
yeah that's such a people people have
been also asking me to sign their arms
and they'll get it tattooed i really
like that that is fun it's a lot of
pressure like
definitely wait till the end of the line
of the meet and greet but
because i want to think about it
actually ask me in the beginning and
then wait till the end i was in my show
in new york i i left
and there was a girl standing outside
the door
and she's like will you sign my breasts
and i was like sure
this skinny little thing she pulls up
her jacket she esther do you i was like
she asked her
what is your bra she's a 32 triple d
these are like the best hits i've ever
seen in my life and i signed them and
i'm very proud now did you put your head
next to them to see where they
i feel like this is the perfect first
day of owning a tesla out well i had way
better pants they were low rise like
high up the side
like 90s
but
when i sat down my entire vagina fell
out i was like maybe we'll save that for
the live for the livestream live stream
and i got i ordered you as the funniest
present but they didn't come yet
which i'm really sad about
also i did my hair with it i got one of
those dyson ones
so if it doesn't look good i'm learning
wait that's like that i feel like that
was like the everyone's on everyone's
christmas list this year but everyone's
arguing about it right whether or not
it's worth all that money now here's how
it feels it feels a lot like a tesla
when you first get you go is this worth
it and then you go you start using yeah
it actually is really cool but it's i
have to figure out how to use it better
wait your hair looks really good though
today it didn't i wouldn't say that it
saved any time
[Laughter]
wait so what like how did the tesla
arrive like walk me they just drop you
they drop it off they just send you a
text on the app did you know it was
arriving today or they did they told me
they texted me on saturday and they were
like your tesla's coming in on the first
or no wait they text me on sunday
it was like i had a day to prepare my
life
like and i have this [ __ ] shitty
honda i'm like wait i have a question
though
my okay it's elise my honda and the
lease is up
i've never not like traded the car in
for another car so like i know i'm gonna
get i know what you're thinking of like
they're gonna screw you when you turn it
in
yeah they're um i'm screwing you over
gouging no yeah
right but let's just say it looks like
someone took a couple screws to the car
so it's not really maybe it's equal
we're screwing each other
but i don't know if i should get it
fixed first do you like
you're asking her i don't know she has a
trash can in the philippines
that's not called a trash cart it's
called a family heirloom you keep it
yeah we're keeping it forever
yeah in the same way did you have did
you get rid of your other car when you
bought your new car or no that's a sore
subject though but it's a family
heirloom
it's in my garage still and it's like
it's very it might break up my marriage
before it begins why because you want to
keep it because of sentimental reasons
yes and it's taking up room in the
garage and also my it's
park it outside your ex-boyfriend's
house that blocked you
put a poster view in it make it look
like you're just staring at it
annie you're good for the brand i
actually think dave would be okay with
that too
whatever you need to do just get the
[ __ ] out of here let's sell it to a fan
for way more than it's worth no let's
wait i feel a responsibility as your
business manager to go back to this
topic of the car because there's a wire
i just want to tell you the what's going
on with the car it's not the worst a
car's ever been in it's not a bobby car
but yeah
it's definitely a lightly bobbied car
and it's
like there is a wire coming out of it
that i'm not sure is from my car or
something and i haven't had the heart to
bend down and check the wire so what
you're saying is you have to turn in
this leased car it's in bad shape and
you don't know what to do do i fix it
first or do i just turn it in
does anyone in the room know
there's so many boys here who's gonna
fix it for you
just turn it in and swap yeah oh you
know what i like about you saying that
right now i can see that you've just
been pulling your hair kind of like back
gelled back into like a hand ponytail
yeah so i know that there was like a
a master thought process behind it you
know that schultz said that we're
keeping him down by praising his
baldness
yeah schultz has this whole what else
are we gonna do
what else are we gonna do we're gonna go
carlos this is crazy
he wants he says that we're keeping
carlos down so that he stays single so
that he likes
will still work for us
listen
esther
he has laid next to you all your period
blood is just billowing out of your
vagina
he's just laid there as it just slowly
soaks towards him
on a hawaiian vacation he was not
released to leave the bloody bed
so maybe schultz is on to something
like what are you going to do you know
my wait did i tell you my assistant
moved home
she worked for me for almost under a
month and then
fled to country
i moved to wisconsin
no no no she they want to like have a
family and stuff so they want to get a
house and stuff
there was good reasoning but it was i
was like are you sure was it the youtube
comments that pushed her over the edge
she quit the biz well she'll still i'm
gonna have her work for me virtually so
you're not in the comments you guys
but i but you gotta you have to strap
him down i kept saying to my business
manager i was like we have to like pay
her like more than you think we need to
pay her because i can feel i can feel
the wings starting to grow i'm going to
fly away
carlos let me see your wings esther
we see his wings they're flinging from
the side of his head
but you're right i should just give it
to them [ __ ] it
i just don't think it like i just have
never done it to the point where i don't
know how much money is it is it three
thousand dollars is it ten thousand
dollars is it writer's assistant jobs go
for a thousand a week no the car though
no she's talking about turning in the
car sorry i did go back i did go back i
did go back are we trying to we're
negotiating your money your pay
all negotiations will halt until the
president of my corporation morris
povitsky is present is he still training
he's still in he's doing a stage
wait is that when you do the unpaid
when you're in a restaurant it's like
and they're training you and it's astage
is i think an untrained
or an unpaid training yeah oh lord he's
been on a stage for a while
he's watching training in america i like
the sound of that unpaid training carlos
it's got a ring to it
um should we call like dave or my dad or
something and ask them what you should
do about your car yeah which one what is
dave well dave just gets another one he
does what you he usually does what you i
think we should get three opinions okay
who are we who are our three lifelines
maybe i should call bobby yeah see what
he would do yes okay you call somebody
and then you call somebody i feel like
somebody that we
okay um that should be the theme of this
podcast because we call our
ex-boyfriends every time here let's
start with somebody dave or my dad
doesn't want to hello
isn't dave's working right now he's on
his lunch break we don't allow dave to
choose judd apatow over us
okay
uh are you guys having euphoria
depression yet wait i haven't watched no
family yeah do not tell me i'm not gonna
say no no not about about ending forever
is it forever no
hey dave
sir
david
hi can you hear me
dave
hello dee what the [ __ ] i think he spoke
time
i never hear from him again he's packing
his things out of the place dave he's
driving her garage out your car out of
the car um can you help us with a
question we need an adult
i'll try okay we need an adult in the
room so annie basically is in a
situation where she has to turn in her
least honda civic yeah um i know i know
as a fellow honda civic lease owner
you'll take a part in this um
and
it's trashed completely like it's not
that bad it's in bad shape it needs
something there's a loose wire does she
just show up to the dealer and be like
it is what it is [ __ ] or does she try
to like fix it up before and make it
seem like it's better
oh this is a great question
what
am i being recorded yes legally you are
being recorded
i mean this is really hard because it's
like that thing of i think they're going
to charge you a little more if you just
bring it back and you're like sorry i'll
pay for the difference of whatever it
costs versus if you went somewhere and
paid for it to be repaired and then
brought it in but it's a pain in the ass
to get it repaired before right so is it
my does my is my time valuable but i
wonder how much the little amount is if
i knew like i need to know what type of
thousands we're talking about here
i can't believe of all people he called
me like i guess this is an adult thing
but i'm not a car guy i don't know
cars we do need someone who works at a
[ __ ] mic yeah all right dave we're
gonna we're gonna
[Laughter]
he does have step-dad energy yeah that's
why he's always yelling at you
we're going to call it roger you're very
similar
really would have been cute roger is my
stepdad's jewish so he'll give us the
right answer i think right all right
if he picks up was it wrong
i'd be really sad but based on what dave
said
it's not worth your time to get it fixed
delilah
hey raj
hi sweetie what's up hey i have a
question regarding um a car lease
yes okay just um
hypothetically nothing's happened to my
car but hypothetically in the next three
years i um wreck it wires are coming out
a couple you know bullet holes in the
car right yes and um do i get it
repaired before the end of my lease or
do i return it as is
i would get it repaired before the end
of your lease
why um
why not
is it because it's cheaper
no because you have that coverage and
you know it's um
you could wait like till the third year
why did something go on no no no i knew
you were gonna ask that no nothing that
the car is fine
okay i'm just curious you know because i
am like marquez made some scratches on
our corolla
and
she backed up into a mailbox i have that
same thing that you do
the
um damage control so
i'm thinking of
getting it fixed or touched up in the
third year right before i'm gonna turn
it in so when i turn it in it looks nice
all right you know what else you can do
here's something that you didn't know
though
if at the end of the three-year lease
let's say your car is worth
um
25 000.
but if you can sell it on the open
market for
30 000.
then you can do that
okay thanks raj i think i'll um thank
you for that information i'll call you
after
um okay i'm done thinking about it
okay love you
okay
oh he hung up
first of all you have such a loving
stepdad i'm so jealous like that was so
sweet you don't even have a stepdad like
i didn't have one i want one now
he brought up such a great point i
forgot that least cars like have more
value than they ever have in like the
universe of these cars yes
like this might be what you might
secretly know the most about cars esther
and you're just not spilling she does
know a lot she's tipped happened i told
you she's always keeping notes i forgot
though that there you might be able to
get more
like value for it the dealers might be
so [ __ ] grateful that you're bringing
them something back that they might cut
you a better deal than usual because
they need cars remember they're out of
chips
there's no cars
you are sitting on a pretty penny also
the person who would fix it just heads
up
is a friend of a guy let's do you know
what i mean so it's not like it's like
i'm not going to be going to like
i'm getting the cheapest
he's gonna figure his ways out but the
last time i took it there i did have an
extra dent where i was like where did
this dent come from he got rid of the
other ones and then there was one was
like that's a weird one
i don't know where we land annie on this
but i think that maybe we get it fixed
no your fingernails oh god my hands are
did you get these for the shelters no i
got these three weeks ago and they're
still holding strong
how was it that was flagry it was good
it was we were just talking about that
like
he's so fast yeah that you're like
you almost are like what just happened
and then like move to another thing
you're like
yeah yeah
yeah but i think that we've been able to
we we need collectively to go back and
ask him some more questions yeah because
yeah follow-up episode flagrant too we
thought that meant you get two tries
yeah yeah right right
i want to ask you guys a question
i
on tiktok i was i came across this woman
talking about the one thing that she
will never do in her life and that's to
cohabitate with a man she's like i'm in
a long you know i'm a long-term very
loving relationship but the one thing i
will never do is live with a man because
i just she believes that there's just no
way for how deep the patriarchy has
existed i love this for women to really
or for a man and a woman to really live
in like harmony together um okay todd is
10 years younger than me so 11 years
younger than me so there's chances are
you would think he's gonna die
after me right yeah they will find us
like it's pompeii okay we will be
together i will be clung to him there's
not a [ __ ] chance he doesn't get a
separate room there's no man cave
there's a couch in his office that i sit
on so are you insinuating i'm
insinuating that this lady's bat [ __ ]
[ __ ] crazy but are you also
insinuating that if you know you're
gonna die i'm gonna kill him yes but
todd lives an unhealthy lifestyle for me
because he's trying to like even out
meet you where you're at
but also a really good thing is that if
you have a terminal disease why don't
you just travel to a volcano site and
actually die i would like to be lava i
don't want it to get there i don't want
my parents to have to pay for the
cremation just jump i'll become no but
you'll be fossilized in some ways is
what i'm saying yeah if you just get
magma on you and todd holding each other
that's so romantic i do i do i do like
the idea of dying next to the loved one
oh are you did you see the notebook and
it just you were like this is the only
book was flashing through my head as i
was saying but i was like is this did
this happen
[Music]
let's talk about just egg it is the most
delicious
food i've ever tried i don't understand
how it's so good your parents are
vegan so my parents are completely
plant-based and they tried just egg and
they were like literally singing and
dancing it's so good and that's how i
felt when i first tried it because they
were using it actually on the set at
icarly like they were they had
plant-based options for people and they
made these breakfast wraps i was like
this is the best breakfast wrap i've
ever had i'm not kidding you it's so
good and they make them in these little
like squares so they're easy you just
open it up heat it up add it to a
breakfast sandwich and it's like your
own little like egg mcmuffin at home
it's super fluffy it's cholesterol free
i'm an egg freak so i had trepidations
about it i was like wait is it gonna
taste yeah it is it tastes just like an
egg it's fluffy i make my quiches i make
my scrambles my omelets it's really good
you don't have to worry about a feather
in there or a beak i say that it tastes
i think it tastes better than than eggs
i i definitely stand by that and also
the convenience of it and the fact that
my parents can eat it because they're
plant-based
it just tastes good i highly recommend
it especially if you're looking to make
more plant-based choices it's such a
good easy way to like get that going you
don't have to worry about cracking it
open and it was twins you don't have
that guilt as a twin looking at the twin
eggs like did i just eat myself you guys
show off the new cholesterol-free you by
buying a bottle of just egg today and
doing the planet a solid all at the same
time just egg really good eggs my family
is
they're big wine drinkers
um and
i think there's no better gift to give a
family who loves wine than a box of
bright sellers it's really cool they
curate a box for you each of and then
they it comes with a pamphlet basically
that describes where what region each
wine is from you can pick and choose
what kind of wines you're into so if
you're like a malbec person or if you
like shiraz or if you like sauvignon
blanc you can basically hand pick which
ones you want to send your family and i
think it's just the easiest way to sort
of make yourself like a sommelier like
the amount of wine information i know
because of bright cellars is astounding
dude so dave doesn't know it yet but i
went to their site and i filled out the
quiz and i was very impressed with how
it works because they ask you like
what kind of flavors do you like it has
nothing to do with wine it's like do you
like dark chocolate do you like milk
chocolate they ask you all these
questions and i know dave so i could
answer for him
and he's now going to and he prefers
only red wine so i put that in too so
now he's going to get a box of like
these curated to his taste special wines
and i also clicked like be risky like
take big swings like i want to be
adventurous so i'm just so excited for
him to get that gift of like these wines
curated for him and for his taste i also
think this is the best way if you're
just starting to learn about wines this
is the best way to learn about different
kinds of wines from different regions
and sort of like figure out what you
really like and it's like you opened a
box and sometimes you can leave it up to
them there's an option where you leave
it up to them and say hey surprise me
like esther said you know you want to be
adventurous as
three fine wines
getting better with age we are very
happy to be sponsored by this
company it's so-called such a good
present to get people
the great thing about bright sellers too
is that it's super affordable
you can get six bottles of wine for just
55 that's freaking unheard of and the
quality of these wines are amazing and
wine is such a classy gift that it's a
way to like give that gift more
personalized and not still have to spend
too much money bright sellers is giving
our followers 50 off their first six
bottle box that's six bottles for just
55
a crazy value you guys follow the link
to take the quiz and get started today
you guys can use our link and get 50 off
your first six bottle box for 55 plus
taxes bright sellers is the monthly wine
club that matches you with wine that you
will love get started by taking the
taste palette quiz to see your
personalized matches
[Music]
this is making me think of this fact
that i learned like years ago about um
tim burton and is it helena bottom card
had a baby and it's you they thank you
or
[ __ ] you no not bucky weird little thing
um
no i totally agree they live in
at least when they were together they
were living in houses next to each other
yeah i will i like i'm very pro separate
living quarters because then it's like
you have the option to sleep over and
sleep in the same bed and everything
whenever you want but when you have
separate spaces to go to
then you can come back refresh i know
what it is what you're such a psycho you
love sleepovers so much that you will
make dave have his own room so it feels
like a sleepover every night
i'm on to you [ __ ] i'm on to you
hello esther's ate forever no no you're
older you're 13 forever thank you we
really needed you at the schultz podcast
because he was saying he was basically
accusing me of being fake gay like
faking
i wish
we needed we really needed you in that
no it's real you i've known you so long
it's so real that i don't even know if
it's comfortable for me to talk about
in the status of your relationship right
now
you've been chasing pretty girl like
chasing them around since i met you
like she's esther's perfect up your
skirt height dude
she's just an obstacle but you know i
could see people thinking you're you're
what is it what did we find out the word
gay queer baiting queerbaiting yeah but
you're not
yeah
yeah i was i it was just a moment where
i was like if annie were here you'd be
[ __ ] schultz i'll get him don't worry
shouts did you come after my girls
helena carter said something that like
changed my life forever like my
perception of relationships when her and
tim burton split up she said just
because
it ended doesn't mean it wasn't a
success
and that's whoa that can be chills
yeah because then i thought of all my
previous relationships i always you
always think of like exes as being like
oh this horrible thing that happened and
i'm like no that was such a
um
like
years of learning years of learning
about yourself living with someone else
i don't think anyone would accuse you of
thinking that
of your ex is being gone from your life
you're like you always think back on
them as should i call them and ask them
how my [ __ ] tastes
no but it is i i've been i had like kind
of this weird like
spiritual breakthrough this week that
was like i almost feel like such a nerd
talking about it because it's so crazy
but i just realized how much of my life
is like attachment you know like i'm so
attached to outcomes like being mad in
traffic being mad like any sort of anger
is because i have this expectation that
i think has to
happen and it's like by doing that it's
like i'm setting myself up for failure
because it's never gonna go the way i
wanted to go i'm tensing myself up i'm
stressing myself out i'm like losing my
life by doing that yeah and so i've just
been anytime someone comes up i'm like
what am i like
what what is it that i'm like attached
to like what am i doing like what am i
focusing on i just was like feeling so
lonely in dc because i had been so sick
this past couple weeks like that's right
wait i have been so [ __ ] sick like i
almost canceled dc you got coveted and
then you had this horrible cold like two
weeks after no well covid was over
christmas and then like a month and a
half this cold was yeah but this cold's
been crazy do you think it's long
covered
yeah because it's uh my sister is really
sick right now and she had coveted a
couple months ago and i wonder if it's
just that like
mass mandates are
getting removed and like now the colds
are back and they're better than ever or
whatever yeah it i think it's just a
regular but it was like it just you
forget
it just stayed for [ __ ] ever it was
just like and it just it's like you're
tired because your body's just like
working on this weird saliva snot
i feel so i just feel for anyone that
has cold symptoms because i feel like i
was always sick in high school and i
just that feeling when your throat is
sore and you're stuffy it just makes
life miserable but then the day after
the cold it's like the best day ever
because you feel normal yeah but with
how long the cold is you keep thinking
the next day's the day you're like this
is gonna be the day and then you're like
it's still not the [ __ ] day but again
that's attachment and then i was in i
was in hot yoga
um yesterday and i usually sit i usually
go in the back so i don't look at myself
because i'm like picking my body apart
and stuff oh that's i always say that
about yoga i go to studios that don't
have miracles yeah you don't want to
like i don't want to marry you i'm
trying to get myself like that but then
i went in and i was like you know what
i'm gonna i feel good about myself i'm
gonna go i'm gonna go to the front and i
as i was doing yoga i was like oh i look
great and then i went you know what this
is actually this judgment's killing me
too so it's like i can't i have to love
my body and look at it with no judgment
whether it's good or bad because
our bodies are moving too they're never
gonna we have no control over how they
look and stuff so it's like do you know
what i mean so i just was like i have to
just like
like that is my body
that is so that is literally advice
verbatim that dave has given me and we
know dave is the father of the podcast
he's the grown-up
he he was a godfather he was like you
can't if you have good reviews
you can't
like you can't take them in because then
the bad reviews will also you'll also
have to take you have to just like exist
and then you can't
like i was thinking about then also if
i'm like oh i look so good that's vanity
right like that's my ego i just was
realizing how ego driven i was being and
so it's like and it's hard in our job
obviously it's like kind of i do this
other thing where it's i um
i push for the self compliments
regardless of how i'm feeling it's
almost like the fake it till you make it
so if even if i know
if i look at the mirror i'm not
particularly happy with how i'm i'm
gonna utter the words anyways yeah and
say you you look great well because also
your judgment on whether you look good
or not isn't necessarily correct because
you've just made up right right and i
always tell myself i'm able-bodied i'm
strong i'm breathing i look [ __ ]
amazing like how immediate and that's it
only happened in the last year i could
not get myself to do that for a really
long time because i'm like such a
[ __ ] lie but then my therapist was
like just try it just try to like
improve your self-talk even on the worst
days and see where that takes you and
i'm telling you like it has done wonders
like i am convincing my body because my
my body listens to my to what's coming
out of my mouth right you know so it
responds to that so even if i don't
believe it it my body will believe it my
love handles are listening to what's
going in my mouth
we are tapping into something crazy
though because
it like that is
i know it's two different things of like
i know two different things but
that's like you're training your
subconscious to believe good things
about you so that you feel good about
yourself because the bad because the bad
thoughts are actually just bad habits so
it's just like you know we learn when
we're little from whatever our like
childhood traumas everyone has it you
know you just like learn to like hate on
yourself in these little ways that just
becomes completely the way that you look
at yourself all the time you don't even
need childhood trauma for that what
about like turn on the tv open a
magazine well i mean yeah like that is
[ __ ] child i mean that's what i i
mean just the cha the trauma of being a
child i guess but also like um
that's so funny you're like watching
cartoons you're like i'll never look
like that it's like well you fished your
wish actually looked exactly like that
you actually look [ __ ] exactly like a
[ __ ] looney tune
[Laughter]
the only person in the world that made
that wish happen you and brandon wardell
my manifesting
powers another thing i saw in tiktok is
that possibly and we don't know for sure
but are thin eyebrows coming back
do you think because of the pam and
tommy thing i don't know but i think
it's with the y2k 90s look coming back
i like i want i don't mind it are we
gonna over pluck again no
we can't over pluck we would have to
literally do the putty over our eyes and
not draw them up
we can't over pluck i can't i went back
to aruna yesterday she says hello oh god
we have the same um eyebrow lady
i almost feel like our version of that
trend because i never saw this growing
up but you see a lot now where people
will paint or dye their brows like nude
or you know so it looks like your skin
maybe we couldn't just do that it's like
a temporary fix i just feel like the
thin eyebrows we kind of learned are
from our mistakes are we really going to
let our children but i feel like my mom
was like stop plucking
yeah maybe that's a part of motherhood
is to tell your kids to not pluck their
eyebrows yeah i i don't know what i've
done right in this life but god did
allow my eyebrows to grow back and i'm
forever thankful because i have friends
whose eyebrows never grew back are you
serious yeah and i over plucked i mean
i have pictures where the left brow is
just completely gone i had maybe three i
never do it even i don't know why it was
never i've never seen one person that
plucked their eyebrows the right way
i was like a stressed out parrot that's
how much i plucked my eyebrows i just
kept going and you've always spermed it
out you didn't mean to but you always
had the little spermies
it's like it just looks so bad what are
the spermies when they look like little
sperms when it would like go up a little
do you remember it's like rounded out
right here why is that sperm like
because it looks like it looks like
sperm
not our sperm it's not like all crusty
and
[Laughter]
esther doesn't look at go go she just
bathes in it well you can't actually i'm
just i'm when it's on your lower back
how do you see it i'm
i'm actually almost triggered by this
because i when i was younger thought you
could actually see the sperm swimming
around and was very disappointed that
you can't because i was like oh my god
that's the greatest way to get pregnant
you're like i didn't see any of the
sperm
i looked
there was none in that one
i literally was like i want to get it in
a cup and like keep them as pets what do
you call it like sea monkeys oh my god
see sperm okay new
trash time yeah trash tank idea i'm
listening carlos you jizz in a [ __ ]
uh thing we put water and we send it to
the face and then we make them we make
little necklaces with your sperm a vial
we'll get the little no no and we'll
we'll do that and then we'll get like
little tanks and we'll get all the
little things from like um fish tanks
that you can get like the little
treasure chest and stuff
and it just has splooge around
like house decorations so it's like a
little sperm aquarium what'd you guys
this is what i wanted
this is the type of trash tank idea
you're looking for
we gotta do that i like how they're all
just come ideas
it's just a car company everything
relates to come
they're on brand
we were all calm at one point we should
send them empty for the squirters the
future squirters and then you guys just
try to like really girls just try to
really squeeze out those
weird esther
we were all just come
yeah
i always think about that how we could
have just been a country sock we could
have just been on a sock that grew up i
know that's like that will send me down
such a spiral thinking that way i can't
go there how dirty this act would have
been
i jacked up that [ __ ] sock
well because i was conceived on a one on
a one shot one shot one kill yeah wow so
it's like i'm like does that
is that that's what the eminem song's
about
that's so crazy like no one was trying
they call her the eight mile
[Laughter]
oh god i think i was my dad's like last
um set of splooge
like his last burst of [ __ ] yeah because
he was like in his thing about something
i'm so proud of him yeah well you know
the insides are melting a little bit but
no but i really don't have them
afterwards
you think what you're the last shot yeah
and i think that's why i'm a swimmer
wow
i won the race of his last like come
blast you know you knew this was the
final chance yeah
and you're a twin which is a whole other
thing like what does that even mean what
kind of sperm is that it's two at right
two eggs
i think it was two different eggs at the
same time two different things
so it's does that mean
two sperm
like
there are two there's just no way i've
seen my brother run there's no way he
was there at the same time
do you know what i mean it's like he's
so much lower than me i just took all
the nutrients
like i just [ __ ] you know how i
monopolize conversations imagine the
womb
[Laughter]
this is not new wait that's so crazy
that you shared the womb with someone
like you're the worst candidate for a
wounded roommate a roommate did you come
out first or did he he came out first
but i came out feet first which means i
literally kicked kicked him out
that makes sense yeah
well you made him like stretch it out
first so you could just go out i said
stretch this [ __ ]
she was walking like a cowgirl that is a
very boss move so you just flew out of
there yeah it was our first threesome
but i came out i always imagined my head
was still this big and they had to like
pull me out like that i don't know why
have you guys ever sat next to like a
big celebrity on any flights
and what do you do what's the proto
i walked into this was before i flew
first by the way i somehow got myself
back into coach what do you mean
something i just i ended up back in
coach i just my subconscious was like
you don't deserve this and i went back
to coach
and then i was like flying's terrible
and i was like freaking out i was like
oh because i [ __ ] well cause i hit
status and then if you
yeah so then i did the thing where i was
like oh i'll just get the regular ticket
and then i'll get upgraded and then i
never get upgraded
so it's competitive out there for the
upgrades yeah i'm just paying it i don't
give a [ __ ] i don't even crusty upgrades
um but i um
i walked into an airplane right now this
was actually so incredible and everyone
in front of me was like we're still in
the first class little area
and everyone in front of me was going oh
my god and they were looking over to the
left oh oh my god and i saw it was
benicio del toro okay
and i was like that's amazing and then i
was seeing them go a couple more seats
and then ugh
and they were looking at clay aiken
i was like wow famous fickle there it is
well on my red eye to new york
um
i sat next to blake griffin wow and i
know that he is like a fan of comedy
right like he's part of you guys like
world he does the roast i know that he
knows santino and whatnot and i was in
my sleepover by esther tie-dye sweater
and um i you know how just a separator
between you can separate yeah and i
usually i'm always the first one to
separate yeah like i don't want to see
you like breathe you in or whatever but
then i was like like i'll smell that
seat
well then i was like oh i don't want to
be rude so i never like put it up and i
was like oh if he puts it up i'm gonna
be really kind of offended yeah but he
never did but then we just you know
slept side by side with just a little
plastic thing between us oh my god
there's like a mutual attractive respect
you guys yeah you guys were like if one
makes a move maybe
yeah but like i i like i don't i never
say anything to any like celebrities
ever so i i was just like you know what
i know carlos was like you know maybe
like invite him on trash tuesday
i was like i don't think i can do that
so i'm just producing behind the scenes
yeah and then honestly that's why you
need you need you need the chatty one
she pushes me esther always makes me do
things like that esther just sends me to
do the work if we were on that flight we
would have been done i would have been
like class
we saw the nikki glazer thing with you
and nikki did it ever happen did you
guys bang i would have been i would have
known every dude i should have texted
you guys so i could have had like an
opening line but on my way back
it was oscar isaac wow
and carlos spotted him before me wait
where's carlos carlos i feel like you're
obsessed with oscar isaac i went to the
bathroom his knees are jerked off
i was actually star struck he was so
handsome in person and i texted him did
your pen did your pants get tight they
don't get tight you don't gain weight
when you get up
okay you kind of do you kind of do
i've never had one i've never had one
butt inside me but only if you strap it
up upwards on your belt line
i think i did really struggle with penis
envy like more so than the average kid
though my parents did think for one
second that might i might go like a
certain direction which they would have
been fine with but
until i was a teenager i was like god i
wish i had a dick i want a dick what i
see i hated dresses i was a tomboy when
i was little but i definitely never
like thought i wanted a penis
yeah i had major penis underneath you
didn't have a penis around that's right
you just had your dad like there were so
many penises around
yeah yeah especially i remember when i
touched me
when i finally got my period even more
the penis envy was even greater because
i was just like this is
let me die
yeah how would we when you got your
period uh 14 14 i was 11. and how old
were you 22. i think i was like 12 or
13. i know i was in sixth grade and i
felt like
i want we did you guys like i wanted it
because like a friend had it and then i
wanted to be like my friend
and then obviously yeah you didn't want
it no my parents would tell me that as
soon as you got your period that i would
peak my athletic abilities would peak
that's so funny and so i prayed every
day i was like please i don't want my
period please i don't want my period so
when i got my period it was devastating
that makes athletics so psychotic it is
iconic that that was not true what they
believed then it was like well she's
only she's got a shelf life after she
you know matures becomes a lady you know
her body is going to change her speed in
the water is going to change it was like
all this [ __ ] that they had me but
um when i got it i cried for a whole
week same with my sister
we like i've noticed
all week every week every time i have my
period
i'll never forget in junior high it was
my first bad period and i i'm sure i've
told you guys this because it's i it's
such a memory i was i was wearing um
short overalls and i bled through but
that's not what color were the jeans
jean
but i ripped down i was in so much pain
i ripped down all the guys off my wall
because i had magazine cutouts of like
girls and guys and everybody all my
favorite stuff i ripped the guys down
and i kept the girls up i was like i
would pay a million dollars for a video
of that
of your [ __ ] uh
your uh
what's her lee cook what's her name
rachel rachel cook like drug ad version
just ripping the things down
[Music]
let's talk about better help because you
know what
all of us every person in this room has
[ __ ] up mental health myself included
i'll be the first in line and i would be
nothing without therapy without help and
that is why i'm so proud that we work
with betterhelp i'll be the first online
because i'm not waiting in line anymore
i'm going online to better help okay
i don't want to wait in line i don't
want to wait in a in a
waiting room with a bunch of other crazy
people i want to be like esther you
don't want to run into esther at the
therapy office you go and the therapist
is crying or like why are you crying
um it's just so good from the from the
comfort of your own home you get to
switch in and out which therapist you
want i think that that is true like i
can't
this is what i used to hate i make a
therapist appointment and now i have to
drive and sit in an hour of la traffic
to go there parking you didn't even
think about parking think about i am
going in stressed yeah i'm going to
therapy to get over my issues with
parking
[Laughter]
that's how they keep you yeah don't get
me triggered on the way in we want you
to check out betterhelp.com trash
tuesday because mental health is a
priority for all of us for 2022 and you
really can't do it alone you really need
some help and if you're not someone that
wants to do the annoying things of going
in person better help has got you
covered do not let it be 20
20 blue let it be 20 20. rose
what option i like to is that sometimes
i don't want to do the video call so i
just do the phone call with a therapist
sometimes i'm looking extra it's just
not feeling like i want to be face to
face with somebody
and i love that they have a journal
feature so if it's five days until my
next therapy appointment and i'm having
big feelings that i can just write them
down in my journal and we can talk about
it in my next appointment i love that
you can communicate with a therapist in
just under 48 hours
that quickly you can switch therapists
as well yeah sometimes it's not a match
and without guilt you could be like all
right i'm gonna go on to next one and
see if this one works and it can be
awkward to have to switch in person and
like this way it makes it so much easier
and i do want to also most importantly
point out that it is an affordable
option for therapy because
we all have those people in our lives
that we are like you need therapy and
then they tell you i can't afford it
right
this is an affordable option and that's
important to have and so i think you can
always present this to someone in your
life
if they're saying they don't have the
money to do it i would say hey oh i just
learned about this it'd be so annoying
if you did that i would be so annoyed if
i was like coming up with my excuses to
not go to therapy and you were like
actually
it's affordable you can't afford it
[ __ ] um now i'm like actually should i
sign all everyone in my family up for
this i have we want you to start living
a happier life today and as a listener
you'll get 10 off your first month by
visiting our sponsor betterhelp.com
trash tuesday join over one million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health again that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p-com
trash tuesday let's talk about nutrafull
because i learned about it actually from
you kalila and
i love that it helps me feel and like
have fuller hair well when i turned 30
the hair just fell off my head i didn't
know why
um it could have been hormonal changes i
was just getting off the pill but
regardless
it didn't happen when you were swimming
you would have been so much faster but
you know i thought about that too
because i had long-term chlorine
exposure because i was a swimmer for so
long so my hair was wrecked
but when i discovered neutrophil i just
i couldn't be more happier with a
product it's not something that you know
fixes your head overnight or you don't
this isn't an overnight fix this is
something that if you commit to for a
couple months you will see results i
know i have i'm so thankful that i found
this product years ago and i have not
missed a day i just had no clue that
your hair aged i just like didn't know
that was a thing
yeah when i look back on pictures of
myself in my early 20s it's like my hair
was so like shiny and full i had no clue
i thought it was thin and you know how
your brain does that but now it's like
it's so amazing that i'm like i'm kind
of like taking back the night with my
hair you know and you know what i
thought too is that oh these baby hairs
just stay baby no when i started taking
neutral my baby hairs grew out
all these tiny little things that i
thought well they'll just sort of stay
that way yeah they grew out my baby
hairs are still they're like in
kindergarten now they're moving up
honestly like
the people who take this the most in my
life are men i they ha it's for women
too i take it too but carlos is taking
it dave is taking it let's wait for
carlos to take it for a little while
before we start telling people carlos
but look at how thick
yeah but for the past
15 years
[Music]
that's the pill you really shouldn't
forget carlos
esther's right they do have a
formulation for men as well you can grow
thicker healthier hair and support our
show by going to nutrafull.com
trash to save 15 off your first month
subscription this is their best offer
anywhere and it is only available to us
customers for a limited time plus free
shipping on every order get fifteen
dollars off at nutriful.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l dot com slash trash
[Music]
this actually changed this actually
changed the course of humanity
this is the
i was on stage my first show on friday
in dc which i had a great [ __ ] time
it was so fun audiences were amazing i'm
on stage i'm wearing jeans
they're not the darkest jeans but
they're not the lightest jeans either
i'm on stage and i hear some girl go oh
my god her pussy's sweating
she goes oh my god did she pee herself
or something like i looked down i had my
fergie moment it wasn't that bad but it
was like just this the level of the
stage she was looking and then i go oh
my god and i like looked down and it was
like just sweating from yeah you know it
was green region where where was it wet
it was just wet
i mean wait you're putting sweat when
you work out because my [ __ ] sweats i'm
not sweaty like you guys i'm just not
either gonna say i've never worked out
it takes a lot for me to sweat oh i
spent there i know i can't stop i swear
everywhere so then i was like oh my god
so embarrassing i had another show but
the green room at this club is a [ __ ]
hotel room so it had one of those little
hair dryers so i got this guy my
videographer filmed me i'm going to make
a clip for it for instagram
trying my [ __ ] in between shows
yeah
it was not the end of the show either it
was definitely the beginning of the show
yeah i'm a [ __ ] sweater i'm with you
annie i feel that pain i have swamp puss
yeah like after yoga it's just
the whole thing as well right here this
was like you know but why don't you
announce it like that oh my god her
[ __ ] sweating
yeah people are drunk i don't know but
like i was like i'm not mad at you i
hate you i'm not mad at you i forgive
you
i had a moment like that that i think
like made me afraid of bathing suits for
my whole life was when i was in middle
school i like was at the the public pool
took off my cover up and like girls from
my house my junior high were like i
didn't know she was fat
and it like i learned in therapy like
that's why i don't own i didn't own a
swimsuit for 20 years like it really you
just went naked
[Laughter]
but like that when you overhear what
someone says and to them they're just
like making a comment and it it will
[ __ ] you up and it's so hard to because
it's like you know you look at it now as
a grown-up and you're like
oh i wish i could have known to not like
attach myself to that like insult but
how you can't you don't have the tools
and you can't you can tell people groans
probably tried to tell us this type type
of [ __ ] all the time well mine didn't
you're done no one attempted to help at
all you know how annie you mentioned um
splooge on esther's back earlier yeah
i have a photograph that i've been
unable to delete i usually delete a lot
of like um sex pictures with exes and
whatnot but there's this picture of just
do a hum on my back you upload them
first to the high the icloud you're not
deleting the [ __ ] i know you i heard
there's this picture of someone else's
come on my back that i physically cannot
get myself to delete what do you think
is the psychology behind that do you
just look really hot in it i do look hot
but also it's so much [ __ ]
oh that's cool it's like yeah well
sometimes
yeah it's good work on my end right you
know guys are always like do you want to
see my [ __ ] you know yeah
guys
you have not had a you do have
guys that always want to show you [ __ ]
they're always sending each other texts
of their [ __ ] toilet [ __ ] they get
like proud of their mess yes okay
sometimes there is a [ __ ] that's worth
seeing do you know what i mean no one's
ever sent you their [ __ ] esther or tried
to no but like i i know the concept of
like i'll i'll get like uh bloody pads
from my college friends
look at how oh no
[Laughter]
bloody you know look at how look at this
you have the girl version yeah
it is weird when it comes out you're
like is that egg yolk it's really the
clots are freaky it's wild so do i never
delete this thing no keep it i love it
oh my god let's make it our new logo
go go it's our logo
i say you literally frank have it framed
and like put it in in your house and the
bathroom it isn't going maybe just can
we see that yeah i'll show it to you i
can't believe i almost didn't ask to see
it yeah esther
i know i i was you were like confused
yeah about period blood
you were like i just wanted to talk
about vaginas you're talking about dick
yeah because the [ __ ] part i'm like well
because you guys were talking about
sweaty vaginas it did make me think of
my own version of that which is like you
know when
i can't believe i'm doing this
you know when like
let go this is how you're gonna squirt
just let go you know when like you
release some
i want to go home
you know when your underwear gets wet
and like discharge yes discharge thank
you
and then you have to like put that like
you peed and then like you have to put
your underwear back on and now it's like
all wet because there was discharge like
that sucks
yeah i actually made it i made a an
executive decision in my life where i'm
gonna buy
like fully new underwear every month i'm
just i'm doing it every month because
why i'm like i have money now why am i
putting on these crusty i mean not dirt
do you not have laundry no i clean them
but maybe i just wear them once because
i was on the road and i was like just
bloodying up all my underwear i was just
[ __ ] it up and then i was like in the
sink washing and i went no they're going
in the trash oh i throw underwear away
i'm done i'm throwing out i'm always
what i'm not washing i'm not saving i i
don't throw it away new but if i destroy
it i've made a new decision like i don't
need to hold on to these stained holes
they don't have to be stained you guys
it is so satisfying to run it under hot
water and see all the blood come out
yeah
no hot water and also you can use
peroxide yeah you can't use hot water
because it's it makes it set yeah cold
water for both mine goes off and then i
use extra peroxide
and you do shallow the peroxide when it
bubbles up yeah and then you use a
little bit of shallots it's such like a
ritual for me um trash tank we have an
event where all everyone shows up with
their bloody underwear and we take it
out we wash it all together and you make
kalila wash all of them yeah esther's
like and i'm over here just watching you
guys you have to be bottomless
i'm ready to present to you the come
photo i i think i'm just more in awe of
how much [ __ ] it is
ultimately i'm going to tell you why you
like it once i see it
oh it's because you look so hot
let me see oh my god you look like give
it to me she looks glazed you literally
look like a glazed doughnut esther i
don't know if you're ready for that show
it to me no
delete it never let her see it
let's see how long she'll go
i don't know if i can see it
[Laughter]
oh my god kalala
isn't it but
that position look at how she's falling
in love why are you making it so loving
don't zoom in all the way
i know what you're looking for i know
what you're looking at you're looking
for you're looking for my labia from the
back
back labia let me see it there i see
some there is backlash of course i'm
engorged you guys
that is a hot photo do not delete that
dear
it's over i i want it let's go for clams
dear dave saw kalila's ass goodbye
you wanted it though
the split the fact that it like kind of
like
went everywhere yeah i was expecting a
puddle did he go like this in front of
it so it like um what is that called
when you like lawn mower your vomit
like if someone throws it and they go
like this and then it just sprays out
the lawnmower is jizz
what is this
something else like what is that
sprinkler sprinkler yeah
i like the lawnmower that sounds like
he's going to grind
in your calendar the day you dump dave
the end of my marriage
dear diary if i get if i get engaged
will you get married will you actually
do it or are you gonna not then no
because then what i'll say is i'm
waiting for annie to get married and
then i'll get because that's what i did
to my childhood best friend
but then she did get married no she's
having a second wedding to try to get
you to get married probably also never
believe me when i say oh i'll have a kid
when you have a kid i won't do it why no
it's like yeah it's like let's get guys
let's get matching tattoos you go first
that's like when my best friend said
i'll quit smoking if you stop um purging
your food because i was bulimic for a
little bit she's like i'll quit smoking
so i was so just keen on like i was like
she has to stop smoking she was smoking
two packs a day
and then i stopped purging and then she
never quit smoking oh my god my dad paid
me a thousand dollars when i quit
smoking he did yeah
he that's interesting how old like i
would be so embarrassed
no i was like 16. oh okay it was like
when i was a teenager when i was like
yeah i quit for like
until i was like like i was like once i
like until all the money was going but i
moved to another i mean the next day
i got so much weed with that at night i
was like does this count as smoking dad
no but um yeah no i figured once i moved
to college it was like i can smoke again
i moved out of the state
it wasn't forever do you know what the
bronx zoo you can name um a roach after
someone
let's go it's like a name name a roach
program
i was thinking maybe we could all maybe
apply for that i would love that you
know you can send your name your name to
mars as well on those little coins well
this is different we can name a roach
after each other carlos can you get on
this
yeah
he's like i'm looking at pictures of
isaac
what's his name isaac oscar was he so
hot carlos he was it's alarming that
you're in show business and don't know
his name annie there's so many two name
if you have two first names it's going
to take me it's going to take me three
years
on the site well i guess i knew him from
the cat one but i didn't like the cat
movie was
oh was that the cone brothers that's
when he came out like he was like his
first big that where he like really yeah
that was his first starting role i
didn't like it that was a little slow i
might like it if i rewatched it but i i
think it's my narcissism because i'm not
good at music so when something's about
music i'm like it's my narcissism too
because if it's just about a guy then
i'm like i don't really i'm bored
it's like men watching our comedy
it's a woman
but yeah i think i want to just start
throwing my underwear out and
will you just send them to me i'll get
them cleaned for you
you know speaking of seeing celebrities
a couple years ago
i was in the netflix building and
this
man walked past me and i
could not believe
how well dressed he was wearing like a
very clean simple black sweatshirt with
black jeans
and he was very tall and fit and i was
just like that man is so well put
together and i look up and it was jay-z
that always happens because you see the
clothes for you're because famous people
are so
not all of them but he just
he looked like a star without even
seeing he's like the big he's one of the
biggest stars in the world so it's like
yeah you see the aura first that's what
mark maron said when he did tiger belly
he's like some people really are just
shiny
and you meet them like you meet certain
stars and you're like oh i know why you
were a star
like there are people that really just
have that essence about them and they're
meant for television they're meant to be
seen they're meant to be on stage and
some are a little
a little taint uh a little uh tattered
tattered and they're meant for podcasts
all
right
we're tarnished
we're shiny but we're working on getting
but some there's some stuff on top
there's some go-go we have to get off
we're a little too
real looking is what i'll say that's a
positive i think we can i think the
three of us glow i've been seeing you
all over [ __ ] billboards yesterday it
makes me so excited
you look so hot in that billboard too
really do you know what i realized they
understand that you're secret hot
and so they know to they know about that
body they put that body secret hot no
because you're hidden under the veil of
a small child thank you it's not that
it's not it's not you look like a very
very pretty child
a feminine child and then they put the
but they put those titties out so can we
finally get to the bottom of what's been
on the board for six weeks no oh okay
what is it which one every week i come
in here and on the board it says esther
runs away from home to l.a after seeing
iron man
i can't wait to hear the
this is okay i'll tell this story wait
can i guess what it is
she runs i can't believe you guys don't
know this this was literally such a big
part of my identity that i had this
story
this is such a throwback i had it
written out in my facebook profile in
college because it was so representative
of how crazy i am
what happened was is i
i can't believe i okay i
surprised my parents by coming home from
school a day early like they were
supposed to come and pick me up this was
the end of sophomore year your mom's
like oh great i have to
wait on her a day early yeah
and i was so excited to like show up at
the house and be like have an excite
excited greeting i get there no one
cares i'm there they're just like oh
you're here like nobody cares
and so that like set the tone for the
night a little bit so you're like i
better i better turn it up amp it up a
little bit
so then
my dad was like well iron man the
original the first one iron man came out
today your mom and i are going to see it
tonight i'm like great i'll come with
and we they're like really excited
because we're going to this big fancy
theater there's like 40 minute drive
away where you like pick the sea sal and
you they serve food but we don't get it
because it's too expensive but we just
know that they're certainly
annoying too you're like in the middle
of eating and they're like served it's
like can you get the [ __ ] out of here in
the middle of [ __ ] yeah and popcorn
is more than enough so
the bucket refills so we see iron man
and i am just like
jazzed like imagine being a sophomore in
college you just saw like one of the
greatest marvel movies of the of the
decade it's your fourth movie
in your entire life you saw it at the
big moviko was the name of it this big
nice theater so i'm just like jazzed and
i'm like i just got back from school i
want to like go out tonight so i'm like
we're driving back
and i'm like
mom and dad i'm like i'm going to take
the car and i'm going to go to leah's
i'm going to go to my sister's house
tonight like i just want to like go have
some fun i'm going to drive by my
ex-boyfriend's house that's what this is
code for and my dad's like you can't
take the car and i'm like
what do you mean like i i'm your
daughter and i want to see my sister i'm
going to take the car like i'm not
trying to go into the city i'm not
trying to go out i'm like i just want to
go to my sister's house they're like no
and like that
no of wanting to do something so
innocent combined with the iron man jazz
of it all right i'm like [ __ ] this i'm
leaving tonight sometime you pushed your
jet pack
so we get home they go to sleep i go in
my room
i book a flight
to new york city
i'm like i'm [ __ ] this is how we get
her to do stuff you have to really
offend her and then she'll get her own
ticket this is carlos learn this
this is like my moment i'm gonna be just
like in madonna's autobiography i'm
gonna show up to times square with eight
dollars in my pocket and i'm gonna make
it and like i was like i'm going to new
york tonight so i i booked my ticket i
call a cab there was no uber i called
this sound like the beginning of the
story of her getting sold into sex
trafficking
i call i call a cab i go to the airport
because oh my ticket it was probably
like nine it was like 10 o'clock at
night when i booked it the flight was
like for 5 a.m so i'm like i'm just
gonna go to the airport now so i like
spend all night at the airport and i
text my friend
my college my old college roommate who
had just moved to la and i'm like
i'm going to new york like madonna style
like we're doing it and he's like well
do you know anyone there i'm like no
he's like do you have a place to stay
i'm like no do you have money no he's
like i don't think you should do this
i'm like what do i do and he was like
come to la i'm here i'll pick you up
and i was like okay so i like log on to
expedia.com or whatever i change my
flight i and i i get on a flight to los
angeles and he picks me up and like
we like we hang out like we have the day
together
there's no location sharing there's no
iphone my parents don't know where i am
the whole day goes by and i'm like
they're gonna [ __ ] be so the whole
because i'm like angry too i'm like
they're gonna call and they're gonna be
like where are you and i'm gonna be like
i'm in l.a
they never call
and it isn't until the next day
i [ __ ] give up because it was a i
call my mom i'm like
hey guys
i'm i'm
do you want to know where i am
and they're like well where are you i'm
like i'm in l.a
and they're like we figured you went
somewhere
didn't care at all i immediately felt so
homesick and i was like
okay and then i'm like i guess i'll come
home tomorrow and they're like you don't
have to
but i just flew home because i was like
so disturbed that nobody cared that i
left
and then i flew home and that was like
my first experience in la and i think
that's like what gotten the bug in my
head to move here how many weird moments
did you have following pretty women
around and asking
their workout plan oh no actually only
specifically one is coming to mind
a very pretty waitress at the newsroom
cafe
um
but yeah that's my story of running away
from home after iron man that does
remind me a little bit of a
moment in hawaii that i had where are
you
like irish could buy it but then she
irish hello them back oh i had to do
that none of you guys didn't know where
i was gone
you guys i was like todd and i thought
esther was gonna [ __ ] be on the plane
yeah so we were like we're like we gotta
get on the plane as soon as possible
it's torrential downpour this was when
we had we had the biggest storm of the
year of like i know the last 20 years so
we brought it upon us yeah so we were on
kauai and it was already raining and it
was like drizzling in the beginning so
todd was like we were recording the
episode and then todd was like i'm going
to get us atvs just so we have something
to do in my head i'm like he did not run
this by me i knew there's no one that's
going to do it you might have done an
atv
but um under different circumstances
duct tape to it my uncles do that [ __ ]
that's so scary they do yes that's in
your dna yes really esther yes the white
trash side of my family is insane they
are atvs do they do
like they have a boat can we visit
them they have a crazy thing they have a
boat
[Laughter]
they they like do all that scary stuff
they hunt and fish we could go to
minnesota we got annie
i know that sounds fun we leave our
boyfriends and start [ __ ] uh
and they would they're such good
midwestern people they would love to
host and be so happy and excited would
you be happy if we left our boyfriends
to be with your family members to be our
family or would you be jealous that
you're not [ __ ] kala no i'd be happy
i would love to have you guys in the
family though right this that you guys
in minnesota and it's a deep minnesota
i would i would send you off with my
uncle i wouldn't go with but
i would
genuinely and i'm not bullshitting you
love that i am down are you okay i've
been trying to okay with all my little
epiphanies and my my spiritual
awakenings i have been
making these little choices to kind of
switch my patterns up so i'm not but so
i've been looking at things like even
when i order food i want to order
something i've never ordered before i
realized i was falling into patterns of
always ordering the same thing
everywhere and so i was like i just want
to like not make different choices would
you ever consider just
trying these crazy things i would
because of what you just said i know
that like all like the self-help work of
like a lot of the choices we make are
just choices we make out of habit
so i do like
throwing in a little different changing
it up is good
sometimes for some things you would just
have to be in the moment of it though
because if you prepare you'll probably
talk yourself out of it right imagine if
esther is actually the best shot she
just kills she just hunts ducks like
no i i wouldn't hunt though that's where
i'm like i don't fit in in this family
when like i open the freezer and there's
all these like animal dead animals like
that freaks me out and that's with dave
that's what they're doing in those
jeddah hotel rooms the rumors were right
i ran away from home when i was five
years old i walked out with the wrong
shoe on the wrong
foot
and my parents did the same thing or my
mom did yeah she didn't come chase after
me
and i remember asking there was like a
fruit stand and i remember asking the
lady just like i'm gonna wait right here
my mom's gonna come get me and she never
did and they were laughing at home
because i wasn't that far away
they were laughing hysterically and kind
of seeing like how far i would make it
and i remember asking this lady at the
fruit stand like will you like adopt me
for a couple days because i don't have a
mom
and the lady i the lady knew my mom
clearly yeah
um but she was also laughing because she
knew what you know she could see what
was happening imagine being a grown-up
and you're a kid right you would be
cracking up you'd be like
get my attention that is i don't know i
think because it's happened to me i
would be like oh no like i would over do
the wrong because that is the right
thing what our parents did is not care
yeah because when you give attention for
that then they just keep doing it yeah
so they must have given you attention
for something yeah i don't know what
went wrong but many things i packed up
my little barbie my barbie suitcase i
had a barbie suitcase but i was so
trying to impress my mom and my mom was
did not like being a girl she was like
really always want to be a boy so i took
i didn't like barb i didn't couldn't
openly like barbie so i took
like a pen and i crossed it off
i crossed the barbie off and i had my
little emo like like anarchy
crossed off barbie suitcase and i went
and i hid behind the tree and like kept
looking to see for when they'd find me
and it just there was too many kids
other kids in the house for them to
notice i love that we've all done this
and nobody cared
that's like the theme of today maybe the
the one run away we run away we're
coming back
and they know it yeah yeah it's not
brides they run away
maybe they know that we're slugs and we
won't get barbs
yeah we'll never get far
yeah because as soon as they didn't i
knew they didn't care i was in la i was
like i want to come home right now and
they were like no it's good we're good
we're fine we love this i love this
thing you explored
you guys thank you for watching we love
you we needed this um
please subscribe to our channel we're
trying to get to 200k and if we don't
get there soon annie's gonna hurt me i'm
gonna [ __ ] kill her she's gonna hurt
me in my vagina so
now they're gonna want me to do that oh
no okay well she'll do it anyways please
please subscribe we want to get to 200k
and buy tomorrow i guess get tickets to
see the live stream at
trash
momenthouse.com
listen we want to include you more the
meeting you guys live is like
unbelievable and incredible and if you
can't make it out to these shows and
we're never all together yet hopefully
something can be planned but
come be with us are we auctioning our
panties that day i don't know we're
gonna discuss that right now we're gonna
make the plan it's gonna be good all
right you guys thanks for watching we'll
see you next week
bye guys
[Music]
you